le Groenland remporte chaque année la
palme du désespoir avec le taux de
suicide le plus fort au monde 8 fois
plus élevé qu'en France mon chef a perdu
son meilleur ami l'an passé
il était bourré quand il a appris que sa
copine l'avait trompé
il était fou de rage
il est rentré chez lui et à cause de
l'alcool il s'étirait une balle dans la
tête
je me suis dit que je n'arriverai plus à
vivre
[Musique]
que j'avais tout perdu
j'ai pleuré tous les jours parfois je
veux au cimetière je pleure et je lui
parle
sous la neige un terrain grand comme un
stade de foot c'est ici qu'on enterre en
moyenne un nouveau jeune par mois
[Musique]
je ne me souviens plus exactement où est
sa tombe elle est là-bas je crois
[Musique]
beaucoup de jeunes sont victimes d'abus
sexuels
des jeunes groenlandais ont connu une
agression sexuelle un drame lit à l'air
alcoolisme qui se joue dans l'intimité
des familles et qui expliquent en grande
partie l'épidémie des suicides le
théâtre est alors le moyen d'évacuer les
traumatismes
au début on est toujours un peu timide
mais en fait ça fait du bien ça libère
oui on se sent plus fort
j'ai bien cru que j'allais sombrer quand
j'ai appris ce que mon frère avait fait
parce que je me suis retrouvée toute
seule
c'était vraiment terrible j'étais un con
sur la table heureusement que j'ai
trouvé ici un peu de soutien
ioël sin 16 ans et la petite sœur du
jeune qui s'est suicidé l'an passé le
meilleur ami de Mosses
comme chaque après-midi elle retrouve
ses amis du théâtre ils vont dans l'un
des rares lieux de Tassila ou les jeunes
peuvent se mettre à l'abri autant du
froid que de leurs parents
quand mes parents buvaient ils nous
disait des trucs terribles du genre
qu'il ne voulaient plus de nous qu'ils
attendaient qu'on meurent mon frère et
moi
quand sa petite copine l'a trompé mon
frère s'est senti abandonné pour de bon
j'ai beau aller sur sa tombe ça ne me
console pas
c'est terrible mais ce chemin du suicide
on a tous été tenté de le prendre un
jour
rejeter durant son enfance à cause de
son apparence féminine et nos 17 ans
assume aujourd'hui pleinement sa
différence dans sa chambre déposters de
stars américaines qui lui ont inspiré
son rêve de devenir un jour comédien je
veux être une star c'est mon rêve ici
c'est ma motivation je rêve de décrocher
un Oscar
les seuls à soutenir ce projet de
théâtre ce sont les parents d'énaux ils
ont grandi dans les traditions et la
pudeur mais se félicitent qu'aujourd'hui
des jeunes lèvent enfin le voile
je trouve qu'ils ont beaucoup de courage
pour revenir sur ces traumatismes
il s'entraide et c'est une bonne chose
je suis sûr qu'ils peuvent faire baisser
le nombre de suicides